la colère populaire entre guillemets ou
d'une certaine frange de la population
elle s'est mêlé d'un sentiment d'
absurde c'est le fameux je crois qu'il
ya un livre qui a été écrit par un
politologue le plus rien à faire plus
rien à c'est à dire que non
seulement on est en colère mais on
estime qu' on veut envoyer péter le
système on veut casser le système parce
que de toute manière il ne rime à rien
c'est sans doute ça à mes yeux le plus
inquiétant en suisse francophone
bien évidemment le spectacle politique
français est jugé particulièrement
haletant
si on le compare à ce qui se passe en
suisse où le personnel politique et même
l'organisation de l'état est beaucoup
plus consensuel donc bien évidemment les
suisses francophones regarde vers la
france ils en connaissent les
personnalités politiques
ils en connaissent les moeurs et la
violence fait partie de cet ingrédient
curiosité on en attend toujours ses
débats extrêmement je dirais eu fort
extrêmement tendu où on va voir
s'affronter des personnalités de bords
opposés ça pour vu de suisse est
typiquement français alors pourquoi
théâtre de boulevard et théâtre de
l'absurde c'est parce que je pense que
pendant longtemps la change du spectacle
politique français et du théâtre
politique français c'est qu'il y avait
toujours la porte de derrière vous avez
comme dans les scènes de boulevard il y
avait toujours la possibilité de sortir
pour se réconcilier dans les coulisses
on avait le sentiment qu'une bonne
partie de cette colère et cette violence
était au fond feinte qu'elle faisait
partie du système
par contre maintenant on est dans le
théâtre de l'absurde
d'abord parce qu'une partie de la
population attend de ces politiques
quelque chose qu'ils ne peuvent pas
amener ils ne pourront pas changer de
mangue ils prennent le monde tel qu'il
est et ils ont des difficultés à le
gérer et d'autre part comme il n'y a
plus cette porte de derrière cette forme
de connivence convivial on va dire comme
les débats entre les politiques sont
devenus de plus en plus orthez sous le
spectacle des chaînes de toute
information continue
eh bien on aboutit à ces situations
absurdes et à mon avis plus
problématique qu'avant
[Musique]